other than that i'm always daydreaming
about
love but the perfect relationship the
perfect life i could have
and i don't feel like i fit in friends
like 100
because i'm just half french half
egyptian and
it seems like the way to find myself is
to go
abroad so
two years ago i decided to join an
international dating website
and two days later only i met andrew
brother i love you i love you so much
you are my bubble come to my heart
from there we talked every day we got to
the point where like hey let's let's get
together what city do you want to come
to
she says you always wanted to go to las
vegas
i was really nervous to go meet amir i
had done all this work i had prepared
like this entire trip for her
in las vegas to set up everything and
all these surprises and all this stuff
and like my heart is beating you know
like a cartoon cat
she came out and she looked like a
supermodel like she walked right out of
a magazine
she just grabs my hand and all that
nervousness
goes away
like that connection that that just that
ease with a person
it's something that you don't always
find you know
after three days we come back to the
hotel room
and he called me on the balcony and i go
and then
he goes on one knee and he proposed me
then i said yes that's how quick he went
you